رفح الدكتور بشار مراد المدير التنفيذي
لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه دكتور بشار اهلا بك هل بلغكم اي شيء
عن فريقكم الذي ذهب الى تل الهوا ومن ثم
هل بلغكم شيء عن الطفله هند
ايضا طبعا اي بالفعل نحن تواصلنا مع طفله
هند وكان هناك اتصال مباشر مع الضحايه في
داخل هذه السياره بعد اطلاق النار المباشر
على السياره حيث افادت هند واختها ان هناك
ك اربعه قد استشهدوا في البدايه ومن ثم
بدانا بالاتصال مع بعض الاطراف لعمل تنسيق
ل ارسال سياره الاسعاف الى المكان واخذ
ذلك ما يقارب ثلاث ساعات حتى تمكنا من
الحصول على تنسيق عبر وزاره الصحه
فلسطينيه تحركت سياره الاسعاف وكان هناك
تواصل مع سياره الاسعاف حتى وصلت الى
الدبابه التي كانت تحاصر السياره
المستهدفه وبعد ذلك انقطع الاتصال بسياره
الاسعاف وايضا قطع الاتصال بالطفله هند
التي كانت تتواصل معنا ايضا خلال فتره
التنسيق للاسف حتى هذه اللحظه نحاول
الاتصال مع كل الاطراف لمعرفه مصير
طواقمنا ومعرفه مصير الطفله هند ولكن
للاسف لم نحصل على اي اجابه حتى هذه
اللحظه متى كان اخر اتصال متى انقطع ذلك
الاتصال عندما وصل الفريق امام الدبابه
الاسرائيليه يعني في حوالي تقريبا الساعه
السادسه
و30 تقريبا بالليل
اي كان اخر الاتصال مع طواقمنا وبعد ذلك
يعني ما فهمناه ان هناك تشويش على
الاتصالات من قوات الاحتلال تنقطع
الاتصالات اينما يتواجد الاحتلال واعتقدنا
ان هذه يعني فتره قصيره و بعد ذلك عند
الاخلاء سيتم اعاده الاتصال ولكن للاسف
حتى هذه اللحظه لم نستطيع التواصل مع
طواقمنا وانقطع الطفله يعني انقطع الاتصال
مع الطفله التي كانت لا تبعد كثيرا عن
سياره الاسعاف وكان الحجز بين سياره
الاسعاف والطفله كانت دبابه وفقدنا الاص
اصال مع الاثنين ا وفي اخر مره تحدثتم مع
هند كيف كان وضعها ما الذي اخبرتكم
به يعني كانت هند مع بنت عمها تبلغ من
العمر 12 عام على قيد الحياه وفجاه ابلغت
هند انهم قاموا ايضا بقتل بنت العم التي
تبلغ 12 عام بالاضافه الى الاستهداف الاول
الذي اوقع
اعتقد خمسه الاجمالي الذين كانوا في سياره
الاسعاف هم سبعه الان هند الوحيده التي
بقيت على قيد الحياه التي هي كانت تتواصل
معنا لانقاذها كانت تتالم كثيرا كانت
مصابه ولكن عندما وصلت سياره الاسعاف
انقطع الاتصال وحتى الان يعني نخشى على
سلام ال طواقمنا وعلى سلامه هند التي طبعا
حتى حتى هذه اللحظه هي طبعا مجهور الامر
لدينا لا نعلم اي معلومات هل تم نقلها ب ب
عبر قوات الاحتلال ام سياره يعني لا
معلومات اطلاقا حتى هذه اللحظه لا معلومات
عن هند لان فريقكم الذي ذهب الى نجدتها
انقطع لاتصال به كما ذكرت لنا لمجرد وصول
سيارات الاسعاف قرب تلك الدبابه التي كانت
تحول دون الوصول الى السياره التي استهدفت
واستشهد جميع من فيها وبقيت الطفله هند
على قيد الحياه وكانت هي التي
تتواصل معكم اذا الان ما الذي تفعلون حيال
هذا الموقف دكتور بشار ما نوع الاتصالات
التي تجرون الان لمعرفه ما يجري مع طاقم
وان كانت الطفله هند قد جرى اخراجها من
السياره واقتيادها الى
مستشفى كما تعلمين المنطقه الان منطقه
عسكريه الدبابات الاسرائيليه الاسرائيليه
متواجده في المكان نحن نحاول التنسيق مع
عده جهات دوليه مثل منظمه الصحه العالميه
بالاضافه الى الصليب الاحمر بالاضافه الى
وزاره الصحه في رام الله لمعرفه مصير
طواقمنا ومصير هند لا يوجد اي اتصال بيننا
وبين الاحتلال نحن ننتظر اي اجابه عبر هذه
الجهات الرسميه للافاده عن مصير هند ومسير
طواقمنا الدكتور بشار مراد المديره
التنفيذيه لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
في قطاع غزه كنت معنا من رفح شكرا لك